what if I told you that right now you
are witnessing a hate crime you might
even be committing the same offense
yourself according to results from a
controversial new experiment millions of
people are guilty of perpetuating a
racist history that dates back over a
hundred years what crime are we all so
carelessly
committing sitting
indoors in the summer of 2023 an online
influencer named mzy captured the
world's attention by walking into
strangers homes without an
[Music]
invitation these events inspired the
work of this man Dr Scott Miller Perlman
works as an assistant to a research
fellow at the people's Institute of
social studies when you analyze the
totality of the consecutive and
consistent racial terrorism that the
average person of color has to endure it
is a miracle any of them are still
breathing so you're saying that just
sitting in this room you and I couple of
camera
guys were being racist without a doubt
think of all of those white only signs
that you've seen in photos from the
Civil Rights era white people have
always placed a premium on indoor space
and refused to share it with blacks
until they were forced to the problem he
explains goes back to the founding
fathers from the moment the first white
person set foot in this country there
was only one rule that applied to every
home in the colony no minorities
allowed now how would you respond to
your critics who
say you can't call the basic concept of
shelter racist when that basic concept
as you call it is weaponized against an
entire Community then yeah you can call
it racist in his new book blinded by the
white Dr Miller Perlman lays out the
background for his theory and showed us
how he's fighting to end the legacy of
racism in his own home the idea of
locking your doors is in and of itself
white
supremus it's classic clan fairy tale
that we all need to lock our doors to
feel protected but every time you slide
that dead bolt across your threshold you
are harming a minority during our
interview we found he does in fact
practice what he
preaches
who who was that I don't know and that
wasn't the last
time during our visit more than 23
perpetually invited visitors as he calls
them entered his home so you're saying
that any person of color at any time can
come into your house for any reason
that's right as shocking as that was
nothing could have prepared me for the
biggest claim to come out of his
research Dr Miller Pearlman conducted a
social experiment involving students at
a university we took an average white
student and told them to make sure that
no one used this door until we said it
was okay if you'll notice the only
people being stopped are
black the only people trying to get in
are black we conducted this experiment
over the course of a week with dozens of
volunteers no matter the age sex height
or weight of the volunteer the only
people that were being denied entry
indoors were
black how many white people tried to go
in well that data fell outside the focus
of this particular experiment we decided
to try our own experiment to see if we
could get the same results our volunteer
fit the criteria of the original
experiment a 25-year-old man average
height and weight and white we also gave
him the same instructions do not let
anyone use the door until we tell you
otherwise for the first hour we didn't
see anyone try to go in or many people
pass by at all after a while we did
notice
this it was after this incident our
producers realized we were conducting
our experiment at a Chick-fil-A since it
was Sunday we decided to pack it in and
present our results to Dr Miller Perman
for
review right here you can see it for
yourself the presence of a white
authority figure was enough to trigger
centuries of Oppression do you think
other conditions aside from racism could
have accounted for the results of our
experiment you'll have to be more
specific if I told you we did it at a
Chick-fil-A I don't see how that could
affect the outcome no then it was on a
Sunday no chickfila is closed on Sunday
God rest on Sunday racism doesn't so
you're saying that even if a business is
closed it's still racism if they don't
let a black person in bigots will always
hide behind convenient excuses in 1923
it was the Bible in 1923 Jim Crow and in
2023 they hide behind a sign that says
closed since our interview Dr Miller
Pearlman has developed an online course
aimed at helping white people avoid
making uncomfortable mistakes when
interacting with black people the online
course stopped communicating all
microaggressions is set to launch this
fall